I'm excited to see him on the stage and
this isn't something we see that often
usually it's a lot of the Japanese
players that are in the brackets and and
maybe like one or two of the American
players making it when it's like these
big events right but this is the chance
for America to knock out our only
Japanese player that's true to be fair
this is like you know he came alone he
defends alone you know it's not like we
don't have to deal with like go Ichi and
fen rich and you know doger cause you
know it's not so bad right like we just
have one darf posh chaos in the building
hiding the hair hiding it he's ascending
he's leveled up he's prepared for the
news like I feel like if when Damascus
meets his next tier list yeah that's
gonna be talk to Cal especially if he
ends up winning this match against
apology man
yeah that's a good point I was I was
thinking of Tosh Kawa elder tone you
know because of the Joe Dirt hair but
now that one to that you know they do
multiple ones yeah there's the same
persons on there like forth like there's
always apology man milk Kelly hunter
yeah and then the Lecce later three oh
yeah that's like the weak version yeah
it's no good you can't have that to be
honest with you though if you if you
heat up the milk in your cereal I don't
you got a bigger issues the Warriors on
those charts are made in Spanish I
wonder if the whole time he's thought
that it was speaking Puerto Ricans and
that's what he but yeah apology man is
not cultured no no not not a man of
culture he's an excellent Dragon Ball
player yeah he's a man of namekian
culture yeah for sure he knows how to
play this character and I like the way
he structures teams and games too
it's always about like building the
strongest thing that allows him to just
excel on like one moment or hit and
really capitalize really solidly I think
I think what that said - I think teen
Gohan was a great pickup for him with
his team especially with him playing
stat mo and this is gonna be an
interesting match because the other
person that we've seen in this top eight
really trying to do that is tachi column
yeah and his team is not big right you
don't have to worry about lots of your
characters dealing with it's not like
you have two to three characters we're
just gonna get posited over and over
it's not quite as bad as it as it is for
most of the teams right but it's still a
bad spot you get stuck in the corner
against piccolo it's pretty rough
especially if he starts I mean he has so
many good ways to just like hit you
that's low risk right stuff like jump
back l with piccolo is really really
solid and kind of non-committal but the
jump back late on the button and Tosca I
was ready to H out of it my apology man
yeah beautifully done see probably an
assist here off the drop into the snap
out and we are started oh yeah didn't
want to see that fuzzy I don't blame her
taja Cawood knows better does not want
to have to deal with any of that great
check there from Ecology man and a
slicer really really common choice from
those scenarios to get this nice switch
EPSS hits but he was already the middle
of a wolf Bank fist I mean I was putting
apology man tried to dragon rush earlier
and then it was dragged across neotec
that afterwards still ready no break
yeah no tech on that road you just kind
of Ryan him over I think that's
important in this match maybe he saw
what super noon did earlier and saw like
okay if you just you know turn on the
offense really chase this guy down he's
gonna be struggling on the back foot
whoa after that level three sparking
from apology man the stories can I want
to try and capitalize here
yeah pouch Kawa I think was really smart
to just run up in block knowing the
sparking was gonna come out after the
assist came out I kicked down gets hit
and this is bad news yeah I like the
conversion off that from apology man
just gonna definitely get a snap out of
this bring it in team go home we're
gonna get those tongue grenades out
[Music]
block this fence man look at that man
hot shower earn that by just blocking
his way out of there you know defense is
rewarded pretty heavily in this game and
there's a lot of really strong defensive
tools to get you out of spots that is
one of those ones where you're just kind
of stuck to em starter - so a lot of
damage on this pop Scout buildings a
meter as well extension here snapping
out bringing in Super Saiyan Goku yeah
sis we're bout to come back up already
built off of this I'm a great tech there
backs off I like to back off into the
jump heavy that we've seen here - what
great reflect punish into the beams yeah
one of those unfortunate situations
where he's already committed to the
reflect and you know you're kind of
already gonna vanish and you're like
okay well I need a lot of damage for it
don't follow up I know follow up on that
but we have a assist coming back up
though about the beam back out the legs
I'm surprised no 2h maybe you tried and
you're a little late beats the tag I'll
take the snap well do the other
characters have some blue live one thing
about thought Scala too is that we see a
lot of reversal level threes from him
see like he's one of those players that
is not like you put him on defense he's
gonna go for it see so that's something
you have to keep in mind when you play
against them
you see more than three bars she's got
to be watching out I think you trying to
do that's get out of the corner to be
honest they end up jumping into it
wasn't able to extended that without
yawn ptosis their apology man who like
though it'd be nice for him to get back
spending some bar vanish hits raw didn't
even pop off the keep last apology man
you can't need to keep my ass and he was
early on the reflects he really just
brinded that bound right like he had a
lot of life and a lot of little hits and
none of it was really like you know one
big sequence
sliding knock down right it will think
this yeah I like that choice takes a
level three for the damage right into
the dragon rush I like it
that's not something that most people
would probably expect he is not he's not
the type of player that normally does
that either yeah and I mean in this
position you know these hits add up
yeah fake goes for the dragon rush after
stash OS up man college defense there
with only Super Saiyan Goku left almost
got it off there are three bars on deck
I don't know the side was broken again
you're talking about earlier about
defense being so rewarding in this game
the patience paid off that's gonna be a
dead Yamcha not even have to spend a bar
there that's a wild 2h2 and the crazy
thing is that this is a to touch match
for apology man and only one hit for
toshko right like you know it's pretty
scary raw level 3 oh my god it was a
touch match right that's all it was it
was like okay he's got three characters
and the two touch man that was just one
hit or apology man to bring this back
has always been really strong that was
almost a punish for the - super - gonna
be damaged I mean he's dead extend that
he's gonna do a touch gone he gave it
all away just like that apology man
reaction level 3 and the beautiful
punish after the milk is getting warmer
right now I teamed up this guy apology
whoa - cool you mentioned how good he is
with a GT go or with the Super Saiyan
Goku place that character and he's
played that character for a long time
right
just see how stable he is he's a really
solid anchor great buttons and he
doesn't need anybody to help set him up
he's just really solid by himself being
a angry as you want but if you're out of
the tournament not much you can do about
it yeah I was scare you ran up dragon
rush looked like it was going to clip
them but the late tag just like a
falling dumbbell vanish into stinking
thoughts our worked out
righto combo when you got clipped by the
to em a really big starter piccolo this
just came off yeah there's a lot of work
doesn't matter anyways on the key blasts
beam beam is down piccolo assists back
up the ball is out it's on yeah we see a
lot of these widths from apology minute
where he's just doing like standing out
standing l trying to pick him in to
think it's gonna be a ki blast I like
those fakes a lot alright should be the
dragon rush this time the end of the
snap it's gonna bring in GT go to try
and make work of him
I got CES Park here I would guess from
top scholar no he just blocks it out and
it's hip for it that's sick then I was
gonna be another snap same situation
Auto combo age legs puts them in the
same spot sparks out he's had enough
that a tashi colony it against the
policy man yeah I got spent some bar
yeah you got six bars spending Bennett's
Bennett
mix up here sparks out how I blocked it
but he respected it with a dumb back hey
cousin Dom Charlie young full health
right now rebar so built here for
apology man we're going to snap out
bring in the TT go alright hit away with
the dragon gosh that was a good fall out
I think from apology man he's gone for
the standard incoming so many times now
I really like that idea level 1 level 3
yep piccolo I skill so apology man
finally gets the job done after just
grinding this team down with snap after
snap out there snap
nice job jumping away from that tech
button from sashka I thought he was
gonna get hit by the slicers of the Pima
suspect apparently do better to air
something why I think I was trying to
get jump in there but got hit so I took
a look before he can make that move yeah
one one more as much damage as he can
get it's enough man apology man we were
looking at him being down oh one soul
logo glue laughs and now look at what
coughs coughs sitting he's on a roll the
good news for him though is that it's
similar to what we just saw where if he
gets rid of this Goku this is actually a
really good spot to be the other
characters are one-hit kill that was a
good break it was a long delay before
the dragon Rose came out double bomb
super - in Level three out of the legs a
little bit of pixel health left
nice break again drop off into the tag
works a heartbreaker and that is a great
tag for apology man who have gotten yeah
that's a lot of life he's gonna get back
reflect works out well the costume
but do you have any meter that's the hip
apology there you go apology man taking
it
moving on he's gonna be on top for the
tournament after that playing up against
Panda Global's Nakia Lin the loser Sammy
give it up here for tachikoma though
coming all the way from Japan to compete
here in Puerto Rico